red teaming the practice of simulating
cyber attacks to uncover vulnerabilities
is really valuable but it's often seen
as an expensive and time-consuming
exercise that only large or heavily
regulated organizations can take
advantage of
continuous automated red teaming or cart
aims to change that here's how
in cyber security when we talk about
reducing risk it's essential to remember
that it must be a continuous process of
iterative improvement not a series of
one-time events your business is
evolving at PACE and so are the threats
that you face
traditional red teaming approaches like
penetration testing are highly effective
at identifying potential weak points in
your defenses
however pen tests are usually based on
annual compliance cycles and only
provide a snapshot of your security
posture at that moment in time
they're also limited by time and cost
constraints hence they focus on in-scope
high priority items leaving lower
priority items potentially exposed
so how can the latest in technology help
us here enter cart imagine having an
elite red team continually probing your
systems for vulnerabilities but instead
of humans you have an automated scalable
platform that keeps up with your
organization's changes and the evolving
threat landscape
it can simulate Advanced attack
strategies like credential stuffing
phishing attempts vulnerability
exploitation and more without needing
agents or detailed configuration
a leading cart solution should leverage
and attack surface management or ASM
solution that discovers Shadow I.T and
identifies both known and unknown
exposures
by combining it with an effective ASM
solution cart can then continuously test
all identified Target assets to see if
they're still exposed or if your
remediation steps were effective leading
to this self-reinforcing feedback loop
of Rapid risk reduction
carts automation empowers security teams
to proactively gain resilience and adapt
to evolving threats it brings the power
of red teaming to organizations of all
sizes making cyber security more
accessible and efficient
so if you're interested in discovering
unknown attack surfaces validating your
defenses and maintaining an up-to-date
view of your security posture check out
our other videos or click the link below
to see how cart is delivering the next
generation of red teaming